das ist wirklich eine verblüffende
meldung kann es sein dass ein medikament
das während der schwangerschaft
verschrieben wird wie sexualität und
homosexualität verursacht eine jetzt
veröffentlichte studie legt diesen
schluss nahe
welches medikament ist und wie die
forscher zu diesem schluss gekommen denn
letztendlich zum reifenwechsel
ich verstehe dass dieses thema ein
wirklich heißes eisen ist so möchte
vorher nochmal betonen dass sich hierbei
um eine einzige studie handelt das
ergebnis der studie ist war ziemlich
eindeutig aber man darf nicht vergessen
dass es zuweilen methodische fehler gibt
oder auch in der wissenschaft
schlichtweg gefälscht wird das will ich
natürlich auch nicht unterstellen also
jetzt ganz nüchtern die studie zum
hormon progesteron und seine wirkung auf
die sexuelle orientierung wenn es einem
kind im mutterleib nicht so richtig gut
geht wenn eine frühgeburt droht es zu
wenig wiegt usw
wir verschreiben ärzte gerne progesteron
um komplikationen zu verhindern
progesteron ist ein körpereigenes
sexualhormon dem weiblichen zyklus
reguliert eine wichtige rolle beim
wachstum des kindes im mutterleib spielt
und es spielt auch bei der produktion
weiterer hormone eine rolle so ist es in
die produktion von steroidhormon
eingebunden
die bei stressreaktionen und
entzündungsprozessen wichtig sind
forscher um jun reinisch vom ging für
institute in blumigen haben jetzt
festgestellt dass die gabe des
progesteron enthaltenen medikamenten udo
zu clean womöglich die sexuelle
orientierung des noch nicht geborenen
kindes ein leben lang war einfluss zu
ihre studie haben sie die entwicklung
von 34 kindern verfolgt deren mütter
während der schwangerschaft los zog ihn
eingenommen hat nichts sie war 1959 und
was hat ein richtig geboren worden sie
wurden im alter zwischen 20 und 30
jahren zu ihrer sexuellen orientierung
gefragt gleichzeitig wurde eine
kontrollgruppe befragt worden war
untersuchte das forscherteam eine
elternbefragung die daraufhin aber noch
nicht analysiert worden war
das ergebnis der auswertung
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer deren
mütter während der schwangerschaft dass
progesteron haltige medikament
eingenommen hatten beschrieben sich
signifikant häufiger als b- oder
homosexuell zudem hatten wie viel öfter
gleichgeschlechtlichen sex zitaten diese
ergebnisse legen nahe dass der
vorgeburtliche kontakt mit progesteron
einen
langfristigen effekt auf unsere
sexualität und unser sexualverhalten hat
so reinisch ich finde die studie
bemerkenswert muss dringend die
gegenprobe gemacht werden es muss
schnell aktuelle befragungen geben um
die studie zu bestätigen oder eben auch
in frage zu stellen wäre glaube ich
unverantwortlich wenn jesus ergebnis so
lange unbestätigt im raum stehen würde
oder eben auch das gegenteil
ja dann werden wir natürlich hier drüber
berichten also verpasst keinen clixoom
wie du mehr und dafür drücken einfach
ein abo hier aufs auge einfach
draufklicken und dann mir noch einen auf
die glocke geben
dann bekommt ihr nämlich jedes mal eine
mitteilung wenn ein video und ihr ist es
täglich online geht also besann